Hugh Jackman made Wolverine a worldwide
phenomenon after his betrayal of the
character in the highly successful x-men
film franchise an unknown at the time of
casting the role transformed him into a
household name and Jackman has had an
astounding career ever since stepping
into the role of weapon acts since
leaving the part and effectively killing
the character off in the seminal Logan
Jackman has created some pretty big
shoes to fill and whilst obscene names
bandied about like Tom Hardy Carl Irvin
and Luke Evans I personally think that
there is a far better fit for the role
someone who has recently just been
released from his demanding schedule
that man is Andrew Lincoln Andrew
Lincoln has starred in teachers Love
Actually and this life that most
probably know him for betraying Rick
Grimes in the show The Walking Dead the
TV show became a phenomenon upon its
release in 2010 and a lot of that
success can be attributed to Lincoln
carrying it through its eighth season
run while it may have dipped in quality
as of late it's clear that it wasn't
because of Lincoln's ability to act and
not once his seem like he is phoning it
in or giving it his all similar to this
Jackman always gives a hundred and ten
percent in every role that he takes and
the two definitely share an undeniable
work
with Lincoln Ezra crimes was able to
showcase all of the dynamics that he has
as an eider
and this was the perfect audition to
send him on to bigger and better things
Lincoln can be aggressive intelligent
broken and cold-blooded this emotional
range is needed in order to betray the
Wolverine for several reasons the
character's history is steeped in
tragedy and here's how to witness the
death of everyone that he loves whether
it's having to murder Jean Grey with his
own two claws watching Professor X be
killed and advertently by himself being
cloned was seeing his daughter hunted
and on the run
Wolverine has a lot going on similar to
this Rick Grimes is also dealt with loss
and watching Lincoln act as a man has
not only lost his wife but also his
child cemented that he will be able to
deliver the heartbreaking agony that has
been seen in the x-men films thus far
what is most exciting about this timing
is that it was recently announced that
The Walking Dead star is departing the
show and this would clear up this busy
schedule in order to allow him to act in
other projects something that has been
stifled thus far due to the demanding
nature of working on such a show with
the Disney / Fox acquisition getting
closer and closer by the minute the
house that Mickey Mouse built will
clearly be wanting to record what has
gone before and start afresh with an
actor that can grow into the role and
give it his all
Lincoln is perfect for this and I really
hope that he's given the opportunities
that he deserves upon leaving The
Walking Dead so who do you think should
play Wolverine in future movies do you
agree with my choice or do you have an
even better actor for the role comment
below and let me know as I'd love to
hear your thoughts
thanks very much for taking the time out
to watch this video and if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel as I
post discussions like this weekly and
there will definitely be something on
here that you know recently I discussed
the Snyder Code of Justice League as
well as the ending of Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom and where I think the
sequels will go you can check those out
at the end of this video again thanks
very much for taking the time to watch
this I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]